well las vegas is becoming such a sports
town and contributing to that is our
soccer team the las vegas lights i'm
spirited and ready to go they are the
sponsors of this segment today and
joining us in advance of tonight's home
match is owner and ceo brett lashbrook
and of course we have cash the soccer
rocker
he's ready to go the coolest mascot in
all of las vegas sports there we go i
can't argue with that
elvis and evel knievel and johnny cash
right in case there's any international
property attorneys out there listening
it's a mix of all of them it's a perfect
las vegas mascot that we're working with
here and just a lot of fun
so brett let's talk about it i i hate to
even admit this on air that i haven't
been to a game yet i need to get out
there they look like so much fun for
people who haven't been what's it like
it is bringing the world's most popular
sport to the world's most entertaining
city uh right in downtown las vegas
those that have been to catchment field
years ago you won't even recognize the
place we brought a new energy a new uh
oleo leolae singing and dancing and
cheering uh sports illustrated call us
the most interesting team in america and
i'm telling you what you don't even have
to be a soccer fan you don't have to be
a sports fan you just have to love a
good time love to smile love to have
time with your family at an affordable
price it's a wonderful experience come
on out and i hear there's a lot of
confetti right i'm all about that
we shoot off more confetti than they do
when the super bowl champion wins right
we you can't have one you can't have too
much confetti right so beginning of the
game half time and of course after every
goal we celebrated in style yeah we're
looking at some video here just look how
much fun that looks i can't wait to get
out there and for tonight's match let's
talk a little bit about that who are
they playing what can we expect to see
so it's tonight at seven o'clock it's
channel eight night uh so we encourage
all of our channel 8 viewers and and
family at home to come on out it's seven
o'clock kickoff tickets start as low as
fifteen dollars ten dollars uh for
groups and we have a four four family
four pack for only forty four dollars
which includes two papa john's pizza so
there's a lot of great opportunities
it's incredibly affordable uh and i
guarantee you you'll have a great time
we guarantee smiles and laughs wow well
you can't beat that price for families
and can people still get tickets even if
the game's tonight absolutely you come
on down to cashman field it's uh
downtown las vegas you can buy them at
the box office or you can go to
lightsfc.com for more information and
cash over here just having the time of
his life
he doesn't turn it off he's unbelievable
his head's so big it doesn't fit in the
findlay toyota anymore i like this move
we got going on here and can people take
pictures and hang out with cash at the
games absolutely not only that but we're
the only team in town that after the
game everyone is invited down on the
field all ages shoot on the goal play
with the mascot run around bring a ball
play catch with your kids whatever it is
it's a family entertainment it's unlike
anything else you got in the city that's
so fun and i grew up here in las vegas
and we needed things like this i'm so
glad we have it and just before we wrap
up you guys do a lot in the community
what are some types of projects that you
guys are involved with so we have our
kicking it forward program where we're
working with charities throughout the
city
to make sure that kids have an
opportunity to experience professional
sports right not only going into the
schools and doing
our school goals program and encouraging
reading but we also reward them for good
behavior for readings goals et cetera et
cetera with tickets to a game because
las vegas has so many professional
sports options we want to make sure kids
of all social economic background have
an opportunity to come to a game well
that's amazing what you guys are doing
and it sounds like so much fun so be
sure to go check out a game whether
that's tonight
uh the 7 pm kickoff at cashman field for
more info to get tickets visit
lightsfc.com or call them at 702 728
goal thank you guys viva lights